Excellent work if you got all these right. We know for the first one, we have
three separate terms separated by addition, so that's a trinomial. This second
expression is a monomial. We have the product of a constant coefficient, 5, and
variables, a cubed, b squared, and c. So just one term. The next expression
contains a square root, so it's not a polynomial at all. It's something else.
Here we have three separate terms separated by addition and subtraction, just
like in the first one. So, it's a trinomial. For 2 m minus 4, I have two
separate terms, so that's a binomial. Negative 20 is a monomial. And finally,
for this last one, I have a negative exponent on this term, so it must be
something else. It's not a polynomial.